27 year old jt brubacher making the
start he's pitched much better at home
for these pirates he has three of his
four wins at home and you can see a 388
earned run average 63 strikeouts in his
65 innings
there's ahmed rosario swinging a fly
ball hit well out to centerfield long
run for reynolds back to the wall and
makes the catch on the run that was a
great catch by reynolds that was a fine
jump a great route he ran to the ball
he arrived just as the ball arrived
perfect timing with a little extension
to get up to the ball
pretty play those are my favorite kinds
of catches pence is making his fifth
start of the year and it'll be his 12th
appearance he has a one-on-one record of
757 earned run average the key for him
today see if he can get that couple of
one of the two breaking balls over and
command his fastball two outs nobody on
no score first inning for brian reynolds
batting right-handed and the air to
right
and
it is
oh dropped
by hernandez it pops out of his ground
reynolds into second with what could be
a double boi cesar hernandez went a long
way out to right
near the foul line
naylor didn't call him off
and hernandez caught it and dropped it
and they're calling that a double and
the indians will send to the plate clean
up hitter eddie rosario strength three
call rosario jump back and brubacher
gets rosario to strike out looking to
start the second inning here is harold
ramirez and jt
is
on here early on through five batters
here's sam hinch's first major league at
battle swing and a miss
that'll do it four strikeouts for
brubacher who's been perfect through the
first three innings there's jt brubacher
nine up and nine down against him how
about this
oh my goodness this is kind of
ridiculous right now
i mean he's getting that ball he's
firing he's pumping strikes in there and
bobby bradley will bat with two down and
the base is empty what is going on
you got jtb going on on father's day
four five and six against jt brubacher
12 up 12 down on 40 pitches indians
still looking for their first base
runner as eddie rosario heads to the
plate and a swinging aligner to right
and caught on a dive by evans
one out
starting to tail away from him and he
was able to meet it with the glove now
harold ramirez a two-homer game
yesterday the pitch to him
wow literally threw his bat at it and
fouled it off never
even remotely close started as a strike
but he stays alive
and there's a high fly ball deep left
field headed to the seats home run
ramirez
the first hit for the tribe is a home
run
and the indians are in front one nothing
i mean he brought the hands in on this
one this was in off the plate
and he got him down the first time and
he smokes that one he was looking at it
and pulled the hands in so i mean to
stay alive after he fouled off the one
pitch and comes back and hits that for a
home run is remarkable frazier's at
second hayes at first with two outs for
stallings over two today headed up the
middle jacob stallings is going to tie
this game a two out ground single the
center brings home frasier it's one off
the place ground ball mr clutch you put
it very well uh these his rbis are
almost always meaningful yeah very
meaningful rbis and that's another one
of those balls too that uh you know if
you're in a
uh what do you call it uh
you know when everybody's on one side of
the field shift shift yeah that's a
routine ground ball out but they
just like when fraser was hitting they
chose to play it you know traditional
and that ball went right through where
you normally would have somebody for the
ship boy do brubacher pitch well today
six and two-thirds he only gave up three
hits one run struck out nine didn't walk
anybody
jason shreve the left-hander and a true
match-up guy
is coming on to face josh naylor eddie
rosario at second he swings grounds one
into the shift into right center it's a
base hit here comes rosario and trying
to throw evans dropped it
in right field and it's an rbi single
and josh naylor has put the tribe on top
two to one
so naylor comes through with a base hit
against a tough lefty his second hit
today his 18th rbi
evans charging in right
gloved it went to throw it and the ball
squirted free and
with two down he's not getting any
rosario anyway
but that certainly eliminated any chance
and now there are two men out
still runners at the corners indians
still on top two to one
and another tough out in that you've got
adam frazier at the plate the pitch hit
on a line shot to deep center zimmer
going back reaches up makes a catch
and so trevor stefan pounds his glove
walking into that first base dugout he's
come through with a scoreless seventh so
far this year the pirates
have had a chance to sweep an opponent
twice
previously
first time came against colorado they
shut off the rockies in the first two
games of that series
and then lost 4-3 in the finale then
against miami in a four-game series they
had a chance to sweep and lost 3-1
in the final game of that series
on the flip side the indians have been
on the verge of being swept
three times prior to this
first time was the first series of the
year in detroit remember they lost
swung on a smash on one hop to first
staggers bradley makes the play flips to
casey for the out well done by robbie
bradley
that is out number two and with two down
jacob stallings will be the batter swung
on grounded to first backhanded by
bradley underhand flip to the pitcher
claus a covering and emanuel klosse has
a three ground ball out inning well the
indians are turning it over to james
karenchak who
yesterday
along with brian shaw had a rough
seventh inning karen check gave up a
three run homer to the river
and he came in and walked a couple of
batters so a chance for a reprieve
karen check mid 90s fastball that wicked
curveball
now two down and the last hope for the
pirates is colin moran
straight three goal
ball game and the indians avoid the
sweep
and find a way to win a game late once
again what a weekend
every game coming down to the last at
bat